foreign
is Keen to show its Air Force in action
but these aging Jets lack modern weapons
it makes shooting down Russian targets
much harder
One Pilot took time out from the cockpit
to pitch for Western planes like the
American F-16 you could be a real hero
it can be a
I've already professional Pilots but
with without a proper tools without a
proper Hardware you can't do anything to
to increase your capabilities so you
need you need this proper tools to be
really deadly but what jets would make a
difference you say Western jet but which
ones
so F-16 is a
is is the best best solution uh exactly
right key right now
typhoons uh it's it's very it's very
capable yet uh but in at the same time
it's very expensive and uh it's very
limited in number
on a trip to the UK this week Ukraine's
president
urged Britain to give his country Jets
but in reality Rishi sunak has very
little to offer I don't think the UK
will be will be sending any Jets the
typhoon is complicated there is not the
full the European supply chain as there
is for for the for the F-16 we haven't
got that many f-35s and they cost about
100 Mil they cost about 100 million each
and were already stretched uh to meet
our to to meet our our commitments uh at
the moment in a reminder of what's at
stake missiles punched through Ukraine's
air defenses on Friday
a residential area was damaged in Kiev
and Strikes smashed into energy
infrastructure
it's a Relentless cycle that Ukraine
can't stop alone
Ibraham Sky News denipro